[Musique]
tokyo veut des jeux olympiques hubert ou
presque tout sera recyclables juste
qu'on lit où dormiront les athlètes à
200 jours de l'ouverture des jeux le
comité organisateur des voix le mobilier
des appartements où logeront les
athlètes les structures de lits seront
faits de carton recyclé et recyclable on
les pros mais solide pour accommoder des
sportifs mesurant jusqu'à deux mètres 10
et matelas seront faits de polyéthylène
qui sera transformé en produits de
plastique après les jeux en tout 18 min
seront installés dans le village
olympique
la construction de ces bâtiments s'est
terminée en décembre et les appartements
seront vendues après les compétitions
tokyo promet également que l'énergie qui
sera utilisée dans ces logements
proviendra de sources renouvelables
[Musique]